good afternoon
michelle introduced me as former student
of clyde
but i think
it's fair to say i i am lifetime student
of clyde
student of
clyde herzmann school of thought school
of education which was one of a kind
i want to
say how honored i feel to be part of
this very important day
to pay my tribute
to the scholar one of a kind scholar
who
graced our careers and our lives
with his
remarkable body of knowledge he held and
he generated
but also with his simple and warm
friendship
today i want to show you a glimpse of
international clyde herzmann in
continuing what michael has already
showed and i want to continue on that
line
uh the project i want to talk to you
about is in a way continuation of
uh our whole
social work on social determinants of
health
during the time that who said
commissioned michael to set up the
social determinants of health the
imminent early learning partnership
acted as the knowledge network for
ecd in this capacity we undertook two
years of in extensive research to do
global environmental scan to identify
policies programs that are working that
are benefiting or counterproductive to
ecd then compile a report and inform
politicians and policy makers on how can
we use ecd this potent social
determinant of health not only enhance
the state of lives of children but also
enhance the population health and make
health a much more
equitable commodity to
attenuate if not eliminate the gradient
the shark gradient that everybody has
been talking about today we see the ses
gradient that we see in distribution of
health
in this capacity we put the report
together to commissioner
and then the commissioner expert of
except excuse me our report
appeared in commissioner's
report as chapter 5 equity from this
start
in this chapter in this report we made
number of recommendations
and
some of the recommendations that are
very
relevant to the project that i'm going
to be talking about were such as
to enhance the state of ecd ecd related
processes need to be monitored and
measured against set of internationally
agreed upon standards
that
building ecd promoting initiatives
around the existing capacities or even
obligations of the states or nations
makes them more
efficient and more
sustainable
and as the
impact of ecd goes well beyond the
borders so should be our efforts we need
to get together pull our resources and
create global alliances to work on ecd
and ecd matters
while this was happening in who
something else was happening in another
un agency
at the committee on the rights of the
child un committee on the rights of the
child something equally significant
seemingly separate
and it took a brilliant mind like clyde
hertzman to connect the dots
the committee on the rights of the child
is the monitoring body of the convention
on the rights of the child the
convention on the rights of the child
was adopted by general assembly in 1989
in recognition of the fact that the
charter of human rights is not adequate
to protect children
overwhelming number of countries right
away ratified the convention by today
193 so you can see the political will
behind this
and by virtue of this ratification they
have to a review their domestic laws and
framework and administrative process to
make sure that nothing is
counterproductive nothing is against
convention everything is aligned with
the principles of convention and be
every five years to report on the state
of children's right in their states
so from 1989 to 2000 the committee had
reviewed tens of reports and had seen
enough and had come to an alarming
observation that although convention
article one of the convention clearly
defines child as any individual below
the age of 18 but most of the reports
coming to the committee are talking
about older children are overlooking the
younger cohort the early years and that
was unacceptable for many reasons on top
of
all the fact that this was hitting the
convention right at the heart of it
the principle of non-discrimination is
the premise of the convention
so
in 2005 the committee took a day of
discussion and analyze this issue to
death and produce a resource and guiding
document called general comment number
seven how to implement convention for
young children
in 2000
late 2005 early 2006 over a fateful
dinner in new york city clyde sat around
the table with number of people
including a gentleman who is still our
collaborator to stay from the committee
on the rights of the child and he
started talking how unsatisfied
committee is with this
with the way nations handle this general
comment it's not serving the way it's
supposed to be it's theoretical etc and
there clyde
light went on
he looked at it and he said this is our
own recommendations in a nutshell here
is a pcd processes that needs to be
monitored here is the processes that
already builds up on the existing
obligation of a nation report writing
obligation and it's a process that needs
global alliance needs
big developmental agencies and child
right advocates to come together and
pull this
so he approached committee with
representatives of unicef and who and
committee took few months and wrote to
us
and invited us to ask
us as in how humanly learning
partnership to act as the secretary of a
project put together an ad hoc group and
start working on operationalizing
general common seven
the argue clyde had put to committee was
that this is a comprehensive wholesome
document prepared in all good intention
but remains
underutilized we just know how to do it
we have to operationalize and make it
easy to use
this is the group we put together help
acted as
as the
secretariat number of un agencies number
of international ngos and then in 2000
by 2008 we had the draft ready and we
showed to the committee the tool we
developed basically was a set of
indicators 17 set of indicators each one
designed to address one particular right
relevant to childhood from right to
breastfeeding to right to play etc all
of the indicators had the same generic
structure they all ask three sets of
questions structural questions what are
the policies and laws and right to
support of that right process questions
what are the programs and initiatives to
act upon the policies that are in place
and finally outcome
what has happened to the children or the
environment of that right as a result of
this structure and processes in place
and this is example of one of the
indicators every time the answer is no
we provide suggestions such as if there
is no initiative to raise awareness
against violence parenthood positive
parenthood
education in service education so on and
then we provide links to these programs
so the countries do not have to start
from
scratch
following the uh completion of the
indicators we received letter from the
committee on the rights of the child
encouraging us to pilot these in
different countries the first country we
went was sub-saharan tanzania
it was a quite successful
but because of expectedly because of
being resource poor country the outcome
indicators were notoriously low we got
150 about 150 evidence of
processes and structures in place in
support of right then we
digitized the tool span cloned it to
spanish version and went to chile chile
pilot was beyond and above our
expectation
it was majorly because this was a pure
and equal partnership between us and
unicef tanzania unicef san diego
ministry of children and unicef
san diego and minister of children of
the country
the pilots cumulatively showed us that
after we digitized the tool we changed
the name to indicators of early
childhood rights and then we launched
the two to the public in 2012
20th of november in recognition of the
day of university of children
the two pilots really showed that this
the mere exercise of using this right
tool is becomes like inventory taking
the governments understand what is in
place what is not and how can they go on
filling the gap in capacity they use
evidence for advocacy and their for
their action plan
and additionally it showed that
carefully designed and
piloted to such as this can really bring
the stakeholders to the table
keep them engaged can
create responsiveness in the government
in a timely manner because the timeline
is every five years report and the
countries have to show some progress at
least in the area of the rights within
that time frame
it can create transparency because that
speaks to itself and equity and
inclusiveness as they are rooted in the
human rights treaties human rights
treaties that are built upon
this non-discrimination
it can be it can
create consensus-oriented
decisions because everybody is involved
from the beginning and they take
ownership on what the data is showing
ownership in the data and promote
accountability
all of which are
pillars to good governance all of which
will enable states
social institutions governments as the
major duty bearers on the convention on
the rights of the child to
play their role more efficiently to
enhance the environments of children
and to
help children to achieve their
developmental maximum developmental
outcome
as we heard today from most of these
speakers and as most of us have
heard from clyde the reason for that is
simple
environments speak to genes and the
genes listen to them so we better make
sure they have something good to
talk about
thank you
you